you unless a further treaty is made with
the EU
and then lists the things that the bill
doesn't do the Scottish Bill does not
purport to deal with any legal rule
affecting the power of Ministers of the
crown synagogue states such a treaty or
otherwise to conduct the UK's relations
with the EU
it doesn't purport to affect the way in
which current negotiations between the
UK and the EU are conducted it simply
regulates the legal consequences in
Scotland of the cessation of EU law as a
source of domestic law relating to
devolved matters which will result from
the withdrawal from the EU already
authorized by the UK Parliament
this is something the Scottish
Parliament is competent to do provided
that it does so consistently with the
priors reserved in the Scotland act to
the UK Parliament and with legislation
and rules of law protected under
schedule four
and two that its legislation doesn't
relate to other reserved matters
parts of the argument of the UK Law
Officers appear to suggest a wider
objection that separate Scottish
legislation about the consequences of
withdrawal is legally untidy politically
inconvenient or redundant in the light
of corresponding UK legislation
but we are not concerned with supposed
objections for this kind which go to the
wisdom of the legislation and not its
competence
so the court in continuity
quotes reasoning and continuity Place
considerable emphasis on the need for
there to be some form of practical or
legal effect or impact of the law on the
reserve matter
that is entirely consistent and in
accordance with the approach taken
anywhere else asbestos case and with the
same way in which my Lord approach
matters in the Imperial tobacco case
and I see it's implicit in the reasoning
of the court in the legal continuity
reference
that
from that it's reasonable to suggest
that holding an advisory referendum
on an issue of international affairs
would not relate to a reserve matter by
the Scottish Parliament
The Advocate General objects at my
written case I didn't relevantly address
the Christian Institute case
but that case I see doesn't assist in
the submissions made by The Advocate
General in this point
uh the case is at uh
ef-771 Authority Tab 10 volume 1.
this is of this reference
ef-771
[Music]
Tab 10 in volume one
uh
for the purposes of this this reference
the relevant issue in the Christian
Institute case was whether a data
sharing Provisions in part four of the
children and young people Scotland act
which made provision for a named person
service to young people we're outside
the competence because they're related
to the data protective directive which
was reserved to the UK Parliament
the Act created a duty to share
information about the well-being of
children which did not depend on the
consideration of whether it would have
been objectively relevant or necessary
for that information to be shared and
that's a paragraph 16 uh
a page ef-778
the court found that although there was
a bespoke regime of data processing
under the children and young people act
2014 it didn't relate to the data
protection act or the data protection
directive
the subject matter of which was
specifically reserved
because it was not truly distinct from
the overlord overall purpose of
promoting the well-being of children
you can find that in paragraph 64 to 66
ef-805
this case Lane the Christian Institute
case turned on an identification of the
core purpose of the legislation
and Provisions in relation to data
sharing were not to be treated as being
distinct from the core purpose
there is however nothing in that
reasoning that affects the points that I
have made
it's true that the Christian Institute
case
is the Martin against most physiology
that's used
and said to represent a well-established
approach
you can see that in paragraph 63 on the
last line and paragraph 29 at ef-791
but the additional facets introduced by
the Welsh asbestos case was not
addressed or apparently identified by
the court
so on the basis of these authorities
in my submission it would seem that a
matter will only relate to a reserved
matter
within the meaning of section 29 2B
in circumstances where
its purpose is directly
and closely related to reserved matter
probably in this context requiring some
actual practical effects such as
imposing some practical restriction or
impediment on the pursuit of a reserve
matter
with an indirect loose or consequential
connection being insufficient
so I now turn to the arguments for the
proposition that section 2 relates to
the union
before turning to the arguments against
that proposition
and for the alternative that is that
section two would not by virtue of the
reservation paragraph 1B of schedule 5
be beyond the legislative competence of
the Scottish Parliament
the argument that the referred
provisions of the proposed Bill relate
to the union I could take reasonably
briefly given that The Advocate General
has set out the case in detail and
maintains that this is the correct
analysis of the law
I say there's no real difficulty as to
what the reserve matter means
I noted the incongruity in the statute
referring to the union of the England
and Scotland rather than the union of
the United Kingdom including Northern
Ireland nothing turns on this
the union is a legal Union between what
were formally politically and legally
independent kingdoms
the purpose of this being reserved is
equally clear
the purpose of the provisions in
paragraph one or schedule 5 and
reserving matters relating to certain
aspects of the Constitution
is that the matters in which the United
Kingdom as a whole has an interest
should continue to be the responsibility
of the UK Parliament at Westminster
and the relevant authorities that I
would refer to in that regard are
imperial tobacco at paragraph 29 Lord
hope of cricated with whom the other
members of the Court agreed that's uh
Paige
645
and that was the point repeated in the
Christian Institute case where again
Lord reads said a similar thing at
paragraph 65 again in authorities that
page EP
805.
the different arguments turn not on any
difference of view or uncertainty as to
the meaning of the Union rather they
turn on what it means for legislation to
relate to the union
the argument against competence has
essentially five elements
the first is this the subject matter of
the referendum question
asking whether Scotland should be an
independent country concerns the unions
of the kingdoms of Scotland and England
the question asks voters to express
their opinion on whether they want the
union to continue
that however does not resolve the issue
just as it didn't resolve the issue in
Christian Institute case that the
subject matter of the provisions in
question was Data protection
a subject matter in the provisions in
the Welsh asbestos case was raising
money for the Health Service
and as the court explained in legal
continuity case legislation relating to
international relations by would not by
didn't of its subject matter alone
relate to the reserved matter of
international relations
secondly as we've seen
there have been a number of judicial
statements in this court to the effect
that a provision will relate to reserved
matter where the purpose of the
provision has a more than loose and
consequential connection to it
again referring to their Market against
Moses at paragraph 49 Lord Walker on
page of the electronic bundle of 406.
Imperial tobacco paragraph 16 Lord cope
at EP 640
and the legal continuity Bill paragraph
27
again electronic number 835 and also
um to the earlier uh arguments I made
before in relation to Legal continuity
uh at paragraph 33.
I see you referred us a moment ago to
paragraph 65 of
um Christian industry Institute yes
the first the first sentence maybe of
some relevance yes
I'm just getting that one weird it's on
page 805. yes
and the Lord said the first so well the
first sentence struck me as possibly
being
some significance if we're trying to
apply these uh Provisions about reserved
matters
yes so there it says it's important to
bear in mind the central aim of the
provisions in the Scotland that
concerning reserved matters explained in
paragraph 28 that matters in which the U
key has a whole interest should continue
to be the responsibility of the UK
Parliament that that's right
yeah yeah so I saw a Soviet Union and
Parliament itself obviously examples
so the match was listed in schedule five
um such as the union and the Parliament
of the UK
uh
well are obviously examples of matters
in which is UK as a whole has an
interest yes I see that Lord and I
suppose it's uh the question I'll come
on to talk about this a little later is
whether or not
uh legislating about the Union uh is
enough to meet the relates to test
uh when that the referendum is about a
matter that's reserved I think that what
it might be relevant to think that's the
intention of the UK parliament in
creating reserved matters is not be
taken to prevent the Scottish Parliament
asking the people of Scotland about
matters of importance to the Scottish
people even if reserved
it might be thought that the intention
of the Constitutional Arrangements
reflected in Scotland Act was to prevent
the Scottish Parliament unilaterally
changing law and matters that are the
responsibility of the UK as a whole
and the important thing would be to
question whether or not the case law
points to the need for some sort of
direct rather than consequential
practical effect so if we have simply an
advisory referendum we're not actually
taking out of the UK as a whole the step
that would be necessary to give effect
to the outcome of any advisory
referendum I think that's the important
issue that might be Breeze and
connection with the noted statement
about with the purpose of the
reservations and the protection of the
Integrity of the UK Parliament
foreign
so I was dealing with the arguments
against uh competence and the third one
that I would point to is the this that
although the immediate purpose or direct
object of the proposed bill is simply to
ascertain the wishes of the Scottish
electorate on the question of
Independence a wide variety of
background materials which are
admissible aids to identifying the
purpose of legal provision
and refer to Morton against most of
paragraph 25 there
electronic folder page 397
um that establishes that this is
intended by the Scottish government to
be a step towards independence from the
United Kingdom so the background
materials certainly identify the purpose
of a legal provision and that's relevant
here
thus the argument is that the bill is
intended to fulfill a manifest a
commitment of the Scottish government
which stated that the SNP was clear that
the referendum must be capable of
bringing about independence and that's
reflected in the SNP Manor Festival
which we have launched and it's at page
ef-6361 tab 112 volume 9.
again I'm totally sorry what was the
page number
6361 thank you
is the s p manifest of Scotland's future
Scotland's Choice 2021 and the
references page 12 in that document uh
and also the Scottish government's
program for government
2021-2022 likewise refers to the
Scottish government obtaining a
democratic mandate from the people of
Scotland to pursue the opportunity of
being an independent country
and that's reflected in the first
Minister's forward in the program for
government
2021-2022 at Pages
6426 uh
and uh 36430
as to effect
the proposed bill would have the legal
effect among other things of authorizing
election officials to administer a vote
and allocating resources to to them to
do so on whether the union should end
it is their argue therefore arguable
it's not devoid of any legal
consequences
fifthly although the referendum would
have more legal effect on the Union
practical effect of a vote would be
politically significant
that point was recognized by the
majority in Miller at paragraph 124
which is in volume five of the
authorities number 57.
and it said it was the referendum
leading the EU had no legal effects that
we a new winds in no way means it's
devoid of effect
and the paragraph the page number there
is 3429 in relation to that quote indeed
the case went on to say on the contrary
it was said to be of great political
significance
at paragraph 125 of Miller
this court quotes from The House of
Lords Constitution Committee in its 12th
report
2009-10 referendums in the UK House of
Lords paper 99 stated that even where a
referendum is advisory only it would be
difficult for Parliament to ignore a
decisive expression of public opinion
and that quote from page
5900 an electronic bundle and is at
paragraph 197 of the House of Lords
committee report
so taking these points together there is
a clearly couldn't a clear including
argument that the Scottish Parliament
doesn't have the power to enact a law
providing for an independence referendum
the union is a matter in which the whole
of the United Kingdom has an interest
and for which the UK Parliament retains
the primary constitutional
responsibility
a referendum on Scottish independence
would have more than a loose or
consequential connection with the
reserved matter of the Union because the
purpose of such a referendum would
include that of obtaining support for
the creation of a Scottish State and the
independence of Scotland from the United
Kingdom
so I understand
the arguments that have been put forward
by you on both sides is
leaving
a state of indecision and
so that you can't advise one way or the
other well you can't positively advise
that a section 31 statement can be made
yes but looking at individual matters
which are raised for instance political
significance
do you submit that it hasn't got
political significance or or you say
it's an irrelevant factor or I see uh be
realistic about it it does have
political significance just as the vote
in relation to the withdrawal from the
EU for UK had great political
significance But ultimately when it
comes to determining the purpose of the
provision
and its legal effect
the political the the political Fallout
of that is irrelevant for this court and
that's really in line with what this
court has said in continuity bill at
paragraph 11 and did it paragraph 33
where the wisdom of the uh the provision
is not for this court the politics of
the issue is not for this court
the and it's just as Lord hope said in
uh when he mentioned the fact that it
the question of is a political
motivation is a different issue so the
politics of this yes the we could see
that would have a political effect but
ultimately for this court this court is
deciding a question of law
in respect of which they do not take
account of the political effect of any
vote that would arise from Scotland in
relation to an advisory referendum that
has to be the approach and it's
certainly the approach that this court
has spoken about frequently in the way
in which they deal with these often
sensitive constitutional matters
and accordingly paragraph 124 Miller
that must be read
yes I'll try it and I think what was
important in
in the Miller case was what lord
neuberger said about
what would then follow on from the
advisors referendum which is that there
would have to be a vote in Parliament
and the members of parliament were Duty
bound constitutionally to vote on that I
can't quite remember his words as to how
they shoot forward but they certainly
had to cut the council's response
constitutional responsibility to vote in
relation to that matter
as to whether or not the approved or
otherwise of the the decision of the
referendum
I do apologize but you also refer to the
background materials are those
background materials admissible so the I
think when we won Luke's at the uh one
two I think paragraph 25 of Martin
against most and the discussion in
Imperial tobacco in the inner house and
in the House of Lords they are relevant
to inform the whole circumstances they
would be relevant to your consideration
as to
the effect
in all the circumstances
certainly they would that's why I refer
to them here they are relevant materials
yeah but I think Miller wasn't looking
at the purpose of the referendum under
the Scotland act who was looking at
something else uh when the it was being
discussed in that case
but there's no question about the
background being relevant But ultimately
the decision of this court is a decision
that has to be won on a purely legal
basis and it is a legal question for
this court
foreign
to the argument that the Scottish
Parliament does have competence to
legislate for the referendum
as I've explained in the anticipation of
the focus of The Advocate General
submission I'll spend more time looking
at this argument and I submit a six
strands to it
firstly we started to retest set out in
section 29 3 is expressly directed to
ascertaining whether the purpose of a
provision having Regard in particular to
its effect relates to a reserved matter
the focus is not on the subject matter
of the question asked of the population
it's therefore not sufficient to
establish the request requisite Nexus
between a legislative measure and a
reserved matter that the legislation
concerns the reserved subject matter or
in the context of a referendum that it
asks people about that subject matter
secondly this court has held that there
must be a direct connection and
sufficiently close connection between
the purpose of a provision and a
reserved matter
and I refer to paragraph 27 of the Welsh
asbestos Greece which I've looked at
previously it's at page 735 of the
electronic folder
further the reasoning of this court in
legal continuity bill
to the effect that the bill of the
Scottish Parliament would only relate to
the reserved matter of international
relations if by its terms it sought to
defruct or interfere with the conduct of
international relations by the UK
government
also suggests that the connection
between an advisory referendum and a
reserved matter would be insufficiently
close and direct
as we've already seen
the court stated that there is
relatively little scope for Scottish
legislation to relate to international
relations
unless such legislation were to purport
to deal with the powers of the Ministers
of the crown to exercise its prerogative
in foreign affairs or to create a state
of law in Scotland which affected the
effectual exercise of that power
that was what we saw in the authority
when we looked at paragraph 32 and again
I'd referred to Pages 837 and 838.
in continuity Bill the Court's reasoning
emphasized the need for there to be some
form of legal or direct practical effect
of the law on the reserve matter for it
to relate to that matter
thirdly
if the exercise of identifying the
purpose of a provision for the purposes
of excluding legislation from the
Scottish parliament's competence by
reference to section 29 3 is analogous
to that adopted in the familiar process
of statutory construction
that suggests a narrower rather than a
wider purpose
being the legally relevant purpose
and in that respect I refer to the case
of crucial Valley against the Secretary
of State for health
she said sorry I didn't catch that yes
our Quinta Valley against the Secretary
of statefood Health
Authority 49 and it's page
ef-291 and ef-2941
I'm referring from there to paragraph a
to that judgment
ef-2941 where it says the Court's task
was in permission was in permissible
bones of interpretation is to give
effect to parliament's purpose and I
quote though from Lord Bingham
so you might not be said that the
concept of purpose in section 29 through
14 actors is a little bit broader than
the rather more precise idea of
parliamentary purpose or intention which
one uses when actually interpreting an
act it doesn't doesn't it allow one or
require one to have regard to a broader
concept of purpose than one would use
strictly for identifying the meaning of
the statute itself
I've just got at the back of my mind for
instance when one's applying convention
rights in the context of
um parliamentary legislation
you ask questions which arise under the
convention rights such as what is the
aim of animal purpose of the legislation
and for that
usually you can have regard not just to
the words of the statute but to the sort
of wider context in which the statute
has been passed isn't isn't it a similar
exercise under Section 293 well I think
that what's important is to see
we're identifying the purpose of a
statutory provision and it's reasonable
enough to look at the canons or the the
legal case the cases I've looked at the
process of statutory construction in
looking at this act so just by it is
important I think by way of analogy and
by way of informing the process that
this court has to go through in order to
understand what's the purpose provision
in section 29 3 is to look at how this
court has in previous cases considered
two particular Cannons of statutory
construction as being relevant and I I
do see that it is important to have
regard to Quinta Valley for example I
know that Lord Reid made reference to
the case Quinta Valley in the inner
house when he was looking at the way in
which to approach the statutory
construction in terms of the Scotland
acts and there are two particular
start to do constructions that are
relevant and should be noticed so the
first is this that the purpose of the
law purpose of a law is in the first
instance to be derived from an
examination of the words used including
any Clause that expressly refers to its
purpose and in that regard I would cite
Bloomsbury International Limited against
the department for environment food and
Rural fears at paragraphs 10 through to
11.
that's at uh the electronic folder
beginning at page 3109 and the
particular quote at 3120 are rely on is
that paragraphs 10 to 11. uh and that
was a lord man's with whom Lord Walker
baroness healed and Lord Collins agreed
so that that case looked to the question
of how you look at the statutory
provision that related to the uh
the landing of fish in the UK and
whether or not the you looked at the
question of you you interpreted the word
Landing by considering whether or not it
you only looked at those fish landed
directly on UK soil or through Imports
or other sources so the the purpose of
the legislation was of particular Import
in the Bloomsbury case
um
in addition to that the second point
that I would make from the two
particular Cannons of statutory
construction that I rely on it comes
from the case or against the Secretary
of State for the environment transport
the Region's ex-party Spath home Limited
which is 2001 appeal cases authorities
at 46
the electronic pages are 285 and the
quotes that I'm going to rely on are at
page 2857 to 2862
in in that particular case
the meaning attributed to words of an
instrument
is an objective question and not to be
equated with the subjective intention of
the minister or other persons who
promoted the legislation
nor accreted with individual members or
even a majority of members of the
legislature
as noted by reference to Legal
continuity bill in the context of
preserved matters the purpose of a
provision May extend beyond its legal
effects but it's not necessarily the
same thing as political motivation
so I think that whilst there is
obviously some care to be taken on
applying those canons of construction
I do see that they point to the legally
relevant purpose of the proposed bill
being the holding of a referendum to
ascertain the views of the people of
Scotland on the issue of Independence
and not the motivations and wider
aspirations of the individual
parliamentarians or members of the
Scottish government
and I would remind the court that
section one of the bill the purpose
provision in the bill
is that it's to make provision for
ascertaining the views of the people of
Scotland
that is the purpose of the bill and it's
clearly stated
the purpose doesn't extend to securing
Independence
the purpose of the bill is to ascertain
the views of the people of Scotland
ascertaining those views is in this bill
the legally relevant purpose and it
would not relate to the reservation of
the Union in paragraph 1B or schedule 5.
the question that would be posed to the
Scottish people is neutral between a yes
and a no vote
the terms of the proposed question are
therefore neutral as to whether Scotland
should be independent
the form of the question to be used is a
has is to be approved by the Electoral
Commission
and it was it is the same form of
question that was used in the 2014
referendum
section 2-5 of the referendum Scotland
act which we've looked at which is a
ef-2175 would require the Electoral
commission to consider the wording of
the question and publish a statement as
to its intelligibility as soon as
practicable after the introduction of
the bill
and more generally the proposed bill is
not directed at any particular outcome
indeed the general provisions on the
conduct of the referendum which are
adopted in the bill by section 4 are
directed towards ensuring a fair and
balanced campaign
such a bill would be could be supported
by parliamentarians and others who want
the Scottish voters to reject
Independence
proposed as neutral
and therefore the motivations and wider
Ambitions of the Scottish government
represent a subjective attention which
is not to be equated with the objective
purpose of the bill
the objective purpose is clearly stated
in section one that is to ascertain
views of the people of Scotland
that is the objective purpose of any
provision which sanctions the holding of
a referendum
the purpose is not changed by the
motivations of those seeking to hold the
referendum
fourthly
I see that section 29 3 requires
particular attention to be given to the
effect of a provision
The Limited legal and practical effect
of a bill to hold an advisory referendum
can be said to support the view that the
purpose of such an instrument is to
ascertain views of the people of
Scotland that relates to the Union in
only an indirect or consequential way
so the legal effects of the bill would
be limited to the facilitating the
holding of a referendum vote
identifying those eligible to vote
the time of the roads and the affirming
that the referendum Scotland act 2020
would apply
bill would not purport to alter or
impede any legal rule constituting or
affecting the union of the kingdoms of
Scotland and England either directly or
indirectly
the referendum would not would have no
prescribed legal consequences arising
from its result
it is not unlike some other referendums
self-executing
for example the 2011 referendum on the
Parliamentary voting system
refers to the legal effects in terms of
organizing and holding of a referendum I
see that these can be argued as not
being legally relevant effects
they would only be relevant legal
effects if the Rel the reserved matter
was the holding of a referendum
but as we've seen holding referendums is
not reserved
to the extent that The Advocate General
points to the authority confirmed Upon
returning officers
and the like
in no way can those be said to be
anything other than Loosely and
consequently connected
to the reservation in paragraph 1B of
schedule 5.
beyond the immediate effect of
ascertaining the will of the people of
Scotland the Practical effects of an
advisory referendum are properly
characterized as speculative and there
is Authority that speculative
consequences do not establish the
requisite Nexus required by section 29
2C
my Lord read an imperial tobacco
emphasized the courts are not equipped
to speculate on what consequences will
follow the enactment of laws Beyond
those that they prescribe
he stated at paragraph 133
electronic folder 592
that the court is not equipped to
predict the ultimate long-term effects
of the provision
furthermore
it can be argued that it would also it
would also not be constitutionally
appropriate for this court to take
account
of the possibility of future legislation
of the UK Parliament
and yell and and others
a paragraph 19.
Lord Justice Lord Jones and Justice
Lewis in the divisional Court emphasized
that the court should not seek to second
guess whether legislation will be passed
by the UK Parliament
at paragraph 19 he said whether any
legislation is to be introduced and the
form that any legislation should take is
a matter for Parliament itself and not a
matter for the courts
and to similar effect
Sir John Donaldson mastered the rules in
R against Her Majesty's Advocate
treasury ex-party Smedley 1985 Queen's
bench at page 666 ctd which is at page
2667 of the folder
said it beholds the courts to be ever
sensitive to the Paramount need to
refrain from trespassing on the province
of Parliament
likewise this court cannot second guess
the UK's parliament's responses if a
referendum returned the results in favor
of Independence
as Lord neubegger stressed in muhan
parliamentarians are not bound to vote
in accordance with the outcome of a
referendum
so therefore in referring to the effect
of a provision in section 29 3
the UK Parliament should be presumed to
have meant the Direct effects prescribed
by the terms of the legislation
and in any event not effects that are
contingent or dependent on future
legislation to be enacted by the UK
Parliament
and
further the following other points can
be made about the wider effects of the
proposed bill
firstly the consequences attendant on
the outcome of the referendum would be
political
the government of the United Kingdom has
given no Assurance or undertaking as to
how it would act if the referendum
returned was a yes vote
even if a majority of Voters were in
favor of Independence then the Practical
realization of Independence would be
dependent on political decisions and
actions of another of a number of
independent parties and bodies in
particular the Scottish government the
Scottish Parliament the UK government
and the UK Parliament
as I just mentioned in muhan Lord
neuberger explained that paragraph 47
that if the issue came before the UK
Parliament following a Scottish vote for
Independence members of the UK
Parliament would be free indeed
constitutionally bound to vote as they
suffered
and the fifth run to the argument is
that the objection that the aim of
schedule 5 is to reserve to the UK
Parliament matters of concern to the
entire UK and comments made by the UK
government in the 1997 white paper
concerning the Integrity of the United
Kingdom can be answered really in much
the same way
the holding of a purely advisory
referendum does not take the question of
the Union out of the hands of the UK
Parliament nor does it purport to do so
the 1997 white paper did not address the
question of referendums and it cannot be
taken as suggesting that the Scottish
government is precluded from
ascertaining the views of the populative
population of Scotland on any subject
matter reserved to the UK Parliament
sixthly
other features of the Scotland act do
support argument in favor of an advisory
referendum being with incompetence
firstly
it is unnecessary implication
of the Devolution established by the
Scotland act that the Scottish
government May negotiate with the UK
government about Reserve matters
it is integral to section 30 of the
Scotland act by which modifications can
be made to for example schedule 5 by
ordering Council approved by both houses
of the UK Parliament and the Scottish
Parliament that the Scottish government
may have regard to and and discuss
adjustments to schedule five
given that section 30 has been used to
modify for example reservations relating
to export credits guarantee Department
there was an order in 1999 and a
relevant statutory instrument and in
addition to that interception of
communications and surveillance
and indeed in solvency law
it's implicit that such modifications
were approved by the Scottish Parliament
and it's self-evident that the Scottish
government must be empowered to discuss
proposed modifications
that is reinforced by section 63 of the
Scotland act I have a copy of that
section but that particularly allows for
the conferral by ordering Council of
functions on Scottish ministers beyond
the general transfer of competence so
section 33 is not in the bundle but I
can pass it up after court
for the for Lords of Milady
section 33 63.
so that allows for the conferral of
functions beyond the general transfer of
competence
and such an order if it's to be made
under Section 63 requires approval by
the Scottish Parliament before it can be
made and the procedures involved in the
transfer or confederal functions is
contained in schedule 7 paragraph one of
the ACT
and I also have a copy of that so
accordingly it has to be that it's
inherited inherent in the entire scheme
of devolution that both the Parliament
and the government can consider discuss
debate and ultimately boot upon proposed
changes to the boundaries of legislative
and executive competence
in order to exercise such functions in
an informed and Democratic way
the government must be able to connect
canvas the views of the people of
Scotland on such issues
reflecting these features of the
Devolution settlement political parties
can and do campaign in Scottish general
elections on policies relating to
reserve matters
testing the views of the electorate in
general elections and such matters and
taking office on the basis of policies
relating to such matters
most obviously of course Scottish
independence
but it might relate to any
of a large number of reserved matters
there are various examples of the
Scottish Parliament debating and passing
motions in respect to preserved matters
as was envisaged from the outset of
devolution and I refer to some detail of
that in paragraph 45 of my case
so it is significant that the theme of
devolution created by the Scotland act
allows reforms of democratic
participation beyond the exercise of the
franchise and generalized elections or
ad hoc constituency elections as a means
for testing the views of the people of
Scotland
uh by we for example citizens assembly
of Scotland convened in 2019 and 20 and
the citizens assembly and climate change
in 2021 which was convened under the
climate change Scotland act added
section 9 of the climate change
emissions reductions Target Scotland act
2019 added by section 9 were both
exercises
in deliberate deliberative democracy
in addition and as I've already
explained the Scottish Parliament can
hold referendums to ascertain the views
of the people of Scotland on particular
issues and it has a regulated process
for holding referendums under the 2020
Act
so the Devolution settlement reflects a
mixture of principles of Representative
deliberative and direct democracy and
also reflected in the fact that
Devolution settlements for Scotland and
Wales now declare that the devolved
institutions can only be abolished on
the basis of a rent for random of the
people of those countries and that
respect I refer to section 63 a three of
the Scotland Act and the government of
Wales act section E1 subsection 3.
uh the Northern Ireland Act of 1999 in
implementation of the international
legal obligations under the Belfast Good
Friday agreement includes our referendum
requirement in respect of Northern
Ireland's police in the UK and that is
section one of that act
so given these these features of the
Scotland
operates there are reasons for
concluding that the Scottish Parliament
is not constrained when ascertaining the
will of the Scottish people and that it
can do so even where the question is
concerned with the subject matter of a
reserved matter
notably both of the citizens assemblies
refer to above produced or
recommendations concerning Reserve
matters
such matters merely by dint of being
reserved
are not as such no-go areas for the
Scottish Parliament or the Scottish
ministers
and they're entitled to ascertain the
views of the population on them
if they could not do so the Scottish
ministers would be precluded from
Consulting the people of Scotland and a
wide variety of issues whether by
referendum or other form of consultation
exercise
by with example casinos or Daylight
Saving Time Provisions do you like The
Zone B9 and L5 or schedule five these
are reservations
so they couldn't for example consult the
Scottish people on whether or not the
way in which our clocks operate in
Scotland which can sometimes be
challenging for young people going to
school in the early in the morning
during the winter times they couldn't
consult on whether or not there is a
reason to consider that there should be
at least some discussion with the UK
Parliament about changing daylight
saving time
so so
I see that the the Scottish ministers it
can be argued are not precluded from
Consulting the people of Scotland on a
wide variety of issues and they are not
precluded but to consult the people of
Scotland on the issue of Independence
so to summarize my points
the words and Provisions of
indicate that they legally relevant
purpose is to ascertain the wishes of
the people of Scotland on their own
future
The Wider motivations and aspirations of
the Scottish government
and other political parties are not
legally relevant
the legal consequences of the bill are
Rel relevantly nil
any practical effects beyond
ascertaining the views of the people of
Scotland are speculative
consequential and indirect and should
not be properly taken into account
it can therefore be argued that the
purpose of an advisory referendum such
as prescribed in the Scottish
independence referendum bill has at best
an indirect or consequential connection
I refer to the Welsh asbestos case at
paragraph 27
and
it has a at least a best indirect or
consequential effect to the union and it
doesn't have a direct or short-term
effect and if they're there to Imperial
tobacco against the Lord advocate in the
inner house at paragraph 133
it doesn't have the connection or
involves some practical impediment or
other effect necessary for it to be
outside competence
so even if the criteria included
purposes that had a loose or
consequential connection to the union
ascertaining the wishes of the Scottish
people
with its purely indirect contingent and
speculative consequences for the union
would be insufficient to satisfy the
test
so kind of then conclude uh on the issue
of the reservation of the Union
whether the referred Provisions relate
to the reservation of the Union depends
to significant extent on how broader
meaning is given to the effect of any
referendum within terms of section 293
if it's effect for the purpose of
determining whether it relates to the
reservation of the Union Embraces the
political consequences of any yes vote
then it may be beyond the competence of
the Scottish Parliament
if however its effect is the predominant
by its legal consequences and immediate
effect
obtaining the views of the Scottish
people on the subject matter of Reserve
matter
then it may not relate to the
reservation and thus would be within the
competence of the Scottish Parliament
so then moving on to the arguments as to
whether or not the referred Provisions
relate to the parliament of the United
Kingdom in that respect refer to
schedule 5 paragraph 1C
paragraph 1C of schedule 5 identifies
that the parliament of the United
Kingdom is a reserved matter
the legal contributors in legal
continuity bill it was held at the
reservation in company encompasses the
sovereignty of Parliament and referred
there to paragraph 61.
argument that the referred Provisions
relate to the reserved matter of the
parliament is as follows
if Scotland became independent this
would involve a reduction in the scope
of the UK parliament's powers and I
refer to moon at page 672 at paragraph
1771
91 and 102.
indeed if Scotland became an independent
country members would no longer be
returned to the UK Parliament from
Scotland and it would become the
parliament of England Wales and Northern
Ireland
the purpose of holding a referendum and
Independence even though it is advisory
in nature would be a purpose that
relates to such a diminution in the
power of the UK Parliament for
essentially the same reasons that I've
given in relation to the issue of the
competence
in relation to the case that the reserve
Provisions do not relate to the
parliament of the UK
the argument that the referred
Provisions do not relate to the reserve
matter of the parliament is as follows
the legal continuity bill
s made clear that the reservation of the
parliament of the UK is not infringed in
circumstances where the authority of the
parliament to change the law is not
affected it therefore dismissed a
submission that section 17 of the UK
withdrawal from the EU legal continuity
Scotland bill
which would have made special specified
delegated EU legislation dependent on
the consent consent of the Scottish
ministers before it could take effect in
Scotland related to the parliament of
the United Kingdom
this court at paragraph 63 held
nor are we proceeded persuaded that
section 17 impinges upon the sovereignty
of Parliament
section 17 does not purport to alter the
fundamental constitutional principle
that the crown in Parliament is the
ultimate source of legal Authority nor
would it have that effect
Parliament would remain Sovereign even
if section 17 became law
the court preferred to analyze any
practical impacts on the ability of the
UK Parliament to realize its policy
goals by reference to section 287 by
means of schedule four
at paragraph 614 the court makes
reference there but the the provision of
section 287 doesn't arise on this
reference
but since the proposed bill would
establish only an advisory referendum
would not purport to restrict the powers
Authority or jurisdiction of the UK
Parliament
it would not be analogous to the UK
withdrawal from EU legal continuity
Scotland bill in having direct legal and
practical effects on the UK legislation
changes to certain of the Articles of
Union can only be affected by the UK
Parliament
that's paragraph one two schedule four
to the Scotland Act
and the UK parliament's constitutional
rule is entirely unrestricted by an
advisory referendum
in the words of this court in legal
continuity Bill the proposed Bill does
not purport
to alter this fundamental principle nor
would it have that effect
so
I would wish to make some concluding
observations then having taken the court
through these arguments
[Applause]
seven that for successive Scottish
parliamentary elections the Scottish
electorate has returned governments
committed to Scottish independence
separately at each UK general election
since 2015.
a majority of MPS from Scottish
constituencies have been elected on the
same Manifesto commitment
against that background and
long-standing consensus that Scotland
has the right to self-determination to
what extent if at all the holding of a
referendum relates to reserved matter is
a question of fundamental constitutional
and public importance
despite the highly charged political
beat it is a question of law
it is therefore a question that could
only be authoritatively determined by
this court
I believe it's in the public interest
that Clarity be brought to the scope of
the Scottish parliament's Power in
respect to this issue
accordingly the Lord advocate in
Scotland hasn't vote for the first time
the right under Scotland act to refer
this to her to this court a Devolution
issue which is not the currently the
subject of litigation
and it's done so for the benefit of the
Scottish Parliament the Scottish
government and the people of Scotland
and indeed people throughout the United
Kingdom
the outcome of this reference is of
particular importance to the Scottish
ministers who have sought to uh who who
would wish to introduce a bill on a
referendum question if uh if an answer
to the reference is given in the
negative and that would be very much
their wish but it is in this case a
matter that I bring before the court as
a result of my routine function as a
lord Advocate and I seek the Court's
ruling in order to inform this
critically important question
there are two issues I think that arise
from early on today that would require
some answer and it may be that we need a
little bit more time to do some further
investigation
I was asked for uh whether or not there
was some information available to
indicate White Walls that the paragraph
1f of the schedule to the ACT relates
only to questions about reserved matters
um
this was looked at before the case and
the in researchers we came across
internal Communications between the UK
parliamentary Council and the Scottish
office
and we do have communications and
between these two offices in relation to
this matter
but there really is no assistance from
the Parliamentary debate or the internal
materials
and
I submit that it's reasonable to suggest
that paragraph 1f reflects recognition
by the Parliament that it's not possible
to foresee all circumstances in a
question about a reserve matter could
arise
and an intention to capture all such
circumstances without exception
one possible explanation for one F not
extending Beyond reserved matters is
that at the time of the legislation
reserved matters Was A New Concept at
the heart of the Devolution regime in
which no existence existing Judas
Prudence was available
and therefore in respect to which it may
have been thought that there is a need
for a particular uh provision under
schedule six to ensure that the
um these questions could be brought to
the further consideration of this course
look it up again but didn't the original
Devolution to the northern Irish
parliament in 1922 didn't operate on the
same model of Reserve matters so that's
something that we've yet to look at the
the Irish background and it's something
that we will do so we couldn't find any
of the explanatory notes uh For What
actors
anything
the Northern Ireland like 1998 but we
haven't looked any earlier than that but
we would undertake that exercise and try
and do the necessary comparative
exercise that might inform I was just
concerned that there was the concept of
reserved matters was slightly older than
1998 but I started to be corrected and
very well well I suppose it was new for
Scotland as for possibly
so that that that's it was is that
possible explanation is all I'm seeing
but there's really no assistance from
the Parliamentary debate or internal
materials we'll continue to Loop but
there was quite an exhaustive search
done before today on that uh
lady Rose asked a question of whether or
not
a member's bill
could be challenged under paragraph 34
of schedule 6.
that's where a member chose to introduce
the legislation and confirmed that
within in their view it was with
incompetence
I would answer this question by saying
it really wouldn't arise in practice
as in practice the Lord Advocate doesn't
refer a bill until after stage three in
that respect
but I wouldn't rule out that it could be
challenged under paragraph 34 in the
right exceptional circumstances so it
could be done but in practice it really
doesn't arise and there's a particular
involvement of the Lord Advocate at
stage three in the private member's Bill
procedure for uh referral to the Supreme
Court on a creation of legislative
competence I'm happy to be helpful if
you were to explain to us what the Lord
evidence role is in a sense tree yeah so
I I can give that in writing
um
I do have a lot more convenient I think
that's possibly more helpful because
it's quite I do have some material here
that could easily be prepared and handed
up along with if we can get some further
background material on the issue of
schedule
for the schedule to the ACT and
paragraph 1f
just to help me stage three what what
does that so that that's in relation to
the point at which the bill has been
introduced
has gone through the the relevant
processes within parliament in terms of
debate committee stage and amendments
and the final stage in the process is
stage three and that's the stage at
which the Lord Advocate would then
consider whether or not as a result of
the terms of the bill or indeed any
amendments that the case should be
referred to the Supreme Court in terms
of the legislative competence issue but
I can easily give my Lord
a flowchart on that yeah I think I've
understood from your explanation thank
you is that something different from the
section 33 process
so this section 33 I just need to check
section 33
um
it would be within that yeah I think
it's part of section 33 process but it's
just called stage three I suppose it's
part of the process within section 33
that there is the scrutiny of the bills
as I understand it stage three is is
essentially the
the temporal period defined in section
33 section two yes right
yes thank you
so unless there's anything else those
are my submissions
you follow the statement
I suggestions
Hello is my lady I'm going to take the
issues of jurisdiction and discretion
together
submissions
under that composite
the starting point we submit for the
issue of jurisdiction in particular
is there is clear and consistent
Authority
including at this elevated level
that it is not appropriate for courts
generally to engage with abstract
questions of law until the facts oh no
and the case law has made it entirely
clear that the facts for this purpose
include whether possible legislation
will in fact be passed
what its precise terms will be
and indeed very often a factual Matrix
to which such legislation actually
applies
that that case law doesn't just identify
those as the relevant facts for the
purpose of the principle
it examines in some detail why the
courts take that position
and I wanted to take you to two or three
authorities if I may
on those matters
the first of them is the attorney
general for Northern Ireland's reference
in this court
behind Part 12 of starting at page 866.
and the relevant page sorry it's made
very inconvenient to give you the start
page if you're doing it electronically
872 is the page I actually want
foreign
at the beginning of paragraph 28 at the
bottom of 872
in general it is desirable that legal
questions be determined against the
background of a clear factual Matrix
rather than a theoretical or academic
issues of law
and then you'll see in the remainder of
the paragraph which I don't read out the
basic reasons for that
it was a theme to which Lord care
returned
in the second of the Attorney General
references I don't take you to that
second attorney general reference
now because we've summarized the
relevant bit in our case
at paragraph 37.
so that's the first set of cases the
second of them
is a decision of law Justice Lloyd Jones
as he then was a Mr Justice Lewis in
yalon to which reference has already
been made
that is the behind tab 56
and the relevant paragraph for our
purpose is on page three three one seven
in the electronics
three three one seven
and as you see Cara 25 says it will
rarely be appropriate to consider such
issues when they may depend in part on
factual matchup matters or future events
since until those factual matters are
established all the events occur the
courts will not be in a position to know
with sufficient certainty what issues do
arise in a particular case similarly
when matters may depend upon will be
affected by Future legislation it will
generally not be appropriate to make
rulings on questions of law until the
precise terms of any legislation are
known and that paragraph off with those
principles and that explanation there
set out was effectively dispositive
on the facts of that case
well in the circumstance of this case
there's a majority in the Scottish
Parliament and we're told the
legislation is going to be proposed and
surely we can take it it's going to be
passed
my Lord I don't think you can I don't
respect take the others take that as
read why not and the people might have
different views MPS haven't yet voted
the mere fact that there's a government
majority may lead to that result and it
may not
for my little charge your shoulders of
that time it's a matter of you to to
take into account but normally the views
of normally the views of courts are that
even if a government has a majority even
if the government is proposing
legislation it doesn't necessarily
follow that it will be passed at all and
if it is Will necessarily be passed in
precisely returns in which it sits when
it's introduced this is you know Essence
a very short piece of legislation
one can hardly imagine
fundamental changes to the question or
to the operative parts of it oh my Lord
you may very well be right I simply
don't know there may be operative parts
that get changed by way of amendment
they may not
um in any event I'm simply on the
principles at the moment rather than
necessarily how it applies here I don't
want to diminish the force of the point
my Lord puts to me I'm not entirely
unrealistic it is a short piece of
legislation and I I suspect that on both
sides cases the issues that would Arise
at the later stage in relation to
competence will arise Come What May and
irrespective of the precise form of
question so I'm not seeking to deny that
um this is in large part as it were a
set up to the submissions I'm going to
make which are of broader significance
in this case about how jurisdiction
Works under the Scotland act where you
will need to bear in mind not just the
facts of this case and the potential
Clarity of the legislation but more
generally how the acts the ACT works and
in particular the in the relationship
between section 31 1 and section one
paragraph one F of schedule six that's
the key bit for present purposes and
that's a bit that isn't confined
necessarily or at all to this particular
piece of legislation so that's the
broader answer of principles the third
of the authorities I wanted to show you
too
um involve one of the members of the
court in Yemen but not the other by this
point uh Mr Justice lures have become
Lord Justice Lewis and we're sitting
with Mr Justice Stone in Council general
for Wales tab 59 page 3530
[Applause]
and the relevant paragraph for present
purposes
is paragraph 33 starting halfway down a
little over halfway down page 3530.
can I invite the court to read
yourselves that paragraph
quite a long paragraph but maybe more
convenient to read it yourselves
foreign
[Music]
foreign
governments Law Officers and everyone
else and legislatures must inevitably
form their own view about whether
proposed legislation is compatible with
various uh super arching pieces of
legislation EG the HRA
there's nothing new or surprising or
unfortunate with the courts uh get
involved in the after legislation is
enacted and not before and the reason
for that is because courts do not in
general terms for all the reasons I've
gone through give advisory declarations
in the abstract
the court specifically noted in that
paragraph as you've seen that the
equivalent Law Officers and the
presiding officer in Wales were likely
to have to form a view
about competence and reference
but they do not seek advisory
declarations prior to the passing of
bills okay
so that's the critical paragraph for
present purposes from Council General
Wales and you will note
that the court of appeal dismissed the
appeal I don't need to go to that
dismissal of the present purposes if you
wanted it's a page
3562 in the authorities bundle and since
the service of our written case on this
reference I.E this reference the court
has refused discourt has refused the
council General permission to appeal
further to this court
but I mean in our case might not be said
that
it's not going to be an advisory
declaration and it's not in the abstract
I mean if if the court rules on the
matter it will be deciding the point in
the context of this bill won't it my
Lord it will but it will be deciding the
point in the context of a draft bill
that hasn't been introduced into the
Scottish Parliament and has yet to go
through those processes and I'm going to
take you through the processes of the
Scotland act invisages before a
reference in relation to a bill can be
made so Lord I don't think this is yes
that this paragraph is directly on all
fours and I fully take the point you put
to me
but um this is the basic rule and the
purpose of taking you to these
authorities is not to say we are
empowering materia
it is to say this is the basic starting
point well-known well-established
against the backdrop of which
Parliament then legislated in the
Scotland act to set up what we will
submit is a a limited set of
circumstances in relation to draft bills
where Parliament where the where the
courts can do
precisely the thing they wouldn't
otherwise do namely to give a view about
the competence to pass particular as yet
unenacted legislation they take it to
the final stage of passing and then the
courts get involved so the Scotland act
1998 and the equivalent uh uh uh other
pieces of devolution legislation
represent an exception
and we submit a narrow and carefully
circumscribed the exception to what
otherwise would be the basic principle
as Adam rated in these cases
it's an exceptional jurisdiction in a
number of ways in also the fact that
it's it this court is exercising an
original jurisdiction yes
um
in proceedings which can only be
initiated by law offices
yes it's very much giving this court a
constitutional jurisdiction
um
so it's it's somewhat different from
uh well for example the judicial review
proceedings in the council General case
my Lord it is and as I say I don't seek
to rely upon these cases of being in
parameteria they're obviously different
you've got to deal with the specific
constitutionally centered
original jurisdiction that is set out in
the Scotland act the question is how far
does that go yeah that's the ultimate
question of interpretation which is the
issue you're going to have to Grapple
with keatings I was going to refer to as
the final in the quartet of cases
establishing the general principle might
be thought to be a little bit closer to
our sort of
situation
particularly in relation to the facts
and keatings is the behind tab 14.
and the relevant
passages for present purposes start on
899
and again I did invite you to go
through them all now
but you will see from the reasoning of
the Court
this is a little uh call away
the reasoning of the court of paragraph
paragraphs 51 in particularly 51 through
to the end of 55.
reject the attempt to invade the cause
into ruling on the
draft piece of legislation for a
referendum of the kind that we're
concerned with and they did so on the
basis of those traditional principles
there were lots of imponderables in that
case
including whether or not a bill would in
fact be introduced and how it was going
to turn out
and many of those imponderables
do at least have some resonance here the
bill hadn't been introduced
as the court put it a draft bill has no
legal status
if introduced a bill may or may not be
passed by the Scottish parliaments of
the Court
the form of the bill introduced may be
different
no matter what its initial forms of the
Court it may be amended
now again it could have been said to
those representing
The Advocate General in that case
well it isn't it obvious
they've got a majority it's a pretty
straightforward piece of legislation but
they were imponderable enough at least
for that purpose to lead the court to
the conclusion that you see set out at
paragraph 55. I thought at that stage
the result of the election wasn't known
my Lord it wasn't so there were more
imponderables here as I entirely accept
but the ones I identified just now were
taken as imponderables as it were from
the reasoning of the Court as you see in
paragraph 55.
so we do submit that that basic
principle is the key starting point
in considering the meaning and effect of
the Scotland Act
and is important in considering
discretion if you get to that stage
I wanted them to turn directly to the
ACT recognizing that this is a question
of interpretation of the Scotland Act
with all its uh status of the government
my Lord the president has just reminded
that's all
and so far as the ACT is concerned I
wanted to make two key initial points if
I may and the first is the legislation
that's the Scotland act sets out a
carefully regulated and specific
timetable
and set of requirements
before a reference
can be made of a bill
so if you go into tab one of
authorizers and get the Scotland act if
I make can I just remind you of the key
provision so far as this is concerned
position essentially is that the bill
must have been passed
or approved
in accordance with any standing orders
that are made
under section 36 1 and 5.
I take that from
power section 33 sub 2 on page 141
so the power to make a reference is
given to the Law Officers that my Lord
the president identified that's 33 1.
mayor of further question whether a bill
or any provision of a bill would be
within legislative competence
and we know what that means that means
that section 29 2 question in other
words the various bases on which would
it would be outside that competence
and then sub 2 subject to subsection
three you may make a reference in
relation to a bill at any time during
the period of four weeks beginning with
the passing of the bill
and then any period of four weeks
beginning with any approval of the bill
in accordance withstanding orders made
by virtue of 36.5 which we'll look at in
a second so the basic position is that
there can be no reference
by the Law Officers under the scheme of
this legislation
until the bill has passed
and then there's a set period of four
weeks
within which the reference has to be
made
so pulsing is the necessary and the
mandatory temporal precondition to the
making of a reference
what then of the stages of the bill is
before you get to that point go if you
forward if you would to page 146.
and have a look at section 36
what this does is to make mandatory
provision for the content of
parliamentary standing orders
the Scottish Parliament
standing order shall include Provisions
you see from 36 1. and then you see the
various stages for General debate on a
bill with an opportunity for members to
vote on its general principles for
consideration of an opportunity for
members to vote on the details of the
bill
and for a final stage at which a bill
can be passed or rejected
so all of those things have to happen
before the trigger in 33 for a reference
can be made and that's for a pretty
obvious reason which is to thrash out
the content and actual detailed nature
of the bill before it gets
for any power to make a reference
is made
you will then see and we don't need to
trouble too much with it but you saw
reference to 36 5 and the approval
process
earlier on in the provision I took you
to and you will see that 36 5
is effectively a reference back to 36-4
not going to go through the intricacies
of that but it is at least worth chasing
through those procedural intricacies as
the alternative to passing as the
trigger point for a reference
in a specific type of situation uh
you've got to have standing orders
making provision for various
uh other sorts of
process that have to be gone through
before the reference trigger point is
reached they are in essence and in very
broad summary
matters where the subject matter of the
bill ought to do with how you get
elected to the Scottish Parliament
okay
so there is an intricate scheme for
standing orders to regulate those
parliamentary stages and they include
provision as you see for detailed
consideration of bills by the Scottish
Parliament
the prescribed legislative stages
include specified opportunities for
legislative reconsideration
after
the Supreme Court determines any
reference so this provision made in this
act not merely for the process that
leads you to the reference jump off
point
but there are also Provisions in the
legislation that deal very specifically
with going back to the Scottish
Parliament after the Supreme Court has
determined a reference
see for that purpose section 36
sub 4
standing all the shall provide for an
opportunity for the reconsideration of
the bill after its passing if and only
if
the Supreme Court decides that the bill
or any provision of it would not be
within the legislative competence of the
parliament so in other words if they you
assume introduction they pass the
statements are made
the bill is primary facing deemed to be
competent it comes to the Supreme Court
the Supreme Court disagrees says no that
provision of that provision that
provision are not within competence
standing orders have then got to provide
for a process what at least for the
opportunity for the Scottish Parliament
to reconsider so that's part of the
built-in process
all of those processes priests oppose
that the draft bill has gone through the
First Essential stage
of introduction
and I'll come back to that because
section 31 and how it works is at the
heart of the interpretive debate
that you will have to Grapple with but
all of those stages I say are preceded
by the requirements for the various
statements and the offering of views
then it gets introduced then you have
the standing orders then you have come
back if the Supreme Court decides any
part of the uh past legislation is in
fact outside competence
you will also have noted
us of it a minute ago that as part of
that intricate structure
are only specified office holders can
refer
see section 33
sub 1
at page one for one and they are The
Advocate General the Lord Advocate or
the uh Attorney General
but you also know just to complete the
intricacy of the process
section 32 sub 2.
which is part of the uh Provisions
governing uh references and so on and
entirely obvious why this provision
needed to be made
32-2 is on page 137 and what it does is
to preclude the presiding officer from
submitting a past bill for assent
if a reference is made within that four
week period
you can see why why you would need that
because otherwise the
first end before The Supreme Court had
offered the Constitutional View
on competence
so the key point to be derived from this
Suite of Provisions with all their care
and intricacy is that the United Kingdom
Parliament and the Scotland act has
required that the stages of the
legislative process in the Scottish
Parliament be completed
the legislation specifically sets the
end of that parliamentary Scottish
parliamentary consideration as the
trigger for the four-week window
referred to in section 33 2.
and the clear intention is therefore at
this stage that the bill in the Scottish
Parliament has gone through all of its
legislative stages
all of those stages referred to in 36 1
so that it is in final form and simply
awaiting a cent that's the only thing
that needs to happen is his majesty
needs to put the Chop on it
it is the point at which the issue
therefore
bear in mind the uh at least the basic
themes from the case law I took you to
earlier it is the point legislatively it
is the point at which the issue that
will come before The Supreme Court is as
close to not being abstract
or incurt as possible
you've done everything apart from
his majesty putting his chop on it
you will also note as part of this
legislative structure and it is just a
note
that there are relevant Provisions
within it and provision specifically
made for orders in Council to be made
that would specifically modify
both of schedules four and or five
you see that from section 30 sub 2
on page 131
and that was a point that was noted by
the law president in Keating is a
paragraph 55 you may have picked up that
reference in paragraph 55 of keatings to
that power and it was that section 30
power which was used to make the order
in 2013 modifying schedule 5 the bits
that we're worrying about when we get to
that competent stage so as to permit the
referendum which took place on the 18th
of September 2014. the order if you
wanted is at uh tab 36 page 2164 but it
followed as you will recall a political
agreement that was reached between
emergency government and the Scottish
government in
2012 which you also have in the bundle
but section 30 for present purposes sits
as part of that scheme you can you can
change it if you want to but it has to
be done by by that process which is
specifically provided for so that's the
first the first point I wanted to draw
attention to in relation to the ACT
sets out a carefully regulated and
specific timetable and set of
requirements before a reference can be
made you can't just do it willy-nilly
it's very carefully done and it's very
carefully done with a with an eye
to all of the line of case store I took
you to earlier it sets of the time point
for jumping off at the point where the
legislation is in effect final apart
from ascent
a second point in relation to the
legislation it is also evident
and Parliament that's the UK Parliament
will have appreciated this fact as well
that a variety of documents are likely
to be created before
introduction
of a bill into the Scottish Parliament
and those documents will normally
accompany the bill at introduction so
explanatory notes policy memoranda
committee reports and so on
I say well normally under the Scottish
Parliament standing orders rule 9-3
9.3 any bill must be accompanied by a
financial memorandum and explanatory
notes and a Scottish government bill has
also got to be accompanied by a policy
memorandum setting out the policy
objectives
see page 6441
in your authorities bundle and this
point is of interest because those sorts
of documents
which may be perhaps to come back to
Lord Stevens less necessary in the
context of a simple bill with a basic
purpose like this but might be very very
important in relation to more complex
legislation which this scheme will have
to govern as well and whatever view you
take on 31-1 in this relationship to
schedule six paragraph on we'll also
have to work for it's of interest
because these sorts of documents have
long been held in your case law
to be particularly important as
informing the consideration of whether
or not the bill or a bill and its
Provisions are within competence
and that is no doubt because 29 3 puts
the spotlight squarely on purpose and
the effect
can you just please give me the page
reference again for rule 9.3
6441 is
that one and the the importance of these
sorts of documents again it's trite so
you probably don't need a reference but
if you wanted one Martin and most per
Lord hope at paragraph 25
page 397 but we've given you a host of
other cases no not unnecessarily in our
uh case at paragraph 13 which are
references to the same end
the point is that those sorts of
documents are likely in many cases to be
integral
to the consideration by this court
of competence and therefore the
Fulfillment by this court of its
constitutional role
and they will be lost
and do those documents also include
um partly political manifestos and
statements by
uh
well by on behalf of a political party
my Lord I'm not sure that those
documents referred to in the standing
order rule will include those sorts of
the documents but I don't think if
that's the purpose of your question that
there's been anything in the case law as
it were the limits for this purpose The
Source but from which you might derive
assistance as to purpose yeah does that
make sense
so the reason that the legislation goes
into this level of careful detail
setting out the pre-enactment safeguards
is obvious the United Kingdom Parliament
clearly recognized that Lots can happen
to a bill during legislative stages
through the Scottish Parliament
including those that must be set up
under the standing orders given the
requirements of section 36 5 that I've
taken you to those processes affect the
shape of what can then be referred the
legislatively in case must become
correct
the United Kingdom Parliament also
clearly recognized that if references
are made in compliance with those
safeguards
the issues that the Supreme Court will
need to consider
will then be capable of being considered
with maximum certainty and with the
maximum degree of assistance that can be
provided to the important constitutional
role and indeed
to Halt back to my Lord president's
point to the original jurisdiction that
this court is then having to undertake
under the section 33 reference
process
and all of this we respectfully submit
was clearly and squarely recognized
I all of this being the basic design and
structure of the legislation
by Lord Caraway in keatings see in
particular paragraph 60
at page 901
[Music]
so perhaps to finish today can I just
make twin submissions at this point in
the argument
the twin submissions are first
that Parliament has been prepared to
countenance
a departure from the usual approach of
abstinence
judicial abstinence but has done so on
terms
as a general rule you don't give
advisory opinions on hypothetical
Provisions in the abstract still less on
proposed legislation because or not
least because that draws courts into
policy making and legislative functions
in a pretty uncomfortable way and you
need therefore the clear parliamentary
Authority that you have in the Scotland
act to enable that process to be
undertaken so the Devolution Devolution
legislation gives you as it were that
legislative permission but it does so in
a very carefully delimited way
that has obviously been designed with an
eye to that case thrust of all of those
Provisions is to try to make as certain
as can possibly be done that by the time
it gets to you the actors in this final
form as can possibly be mustered prior
to it actually becoming law
and the second submission which I leave
you with for the purpose of today is
that with respect the Lord advocate's
interpretation
of the tail end and unspecific words
that finish off schedule 6. paragraph
one f
bypasses slash undermines
all of that
it is no answer
to that point
for the Lord Advocate to say as she does
this is not a bill reference so section
33 is irrelevant
the law Advocate is carefully and
deliberately chosen to frame her
referred question around the terms of a
draft Bill she's no doubt done so to try
to reduce the force of the argument that
it seeks a judicial ruling in the
abstract but the fact
that it is not a bill reference under
section 33 is nothing to the point of
course it isn't
but that is no answer to the objection
that referring a draft bill at this
stage which has not reached the section
33 stage circumvents the exclusive
statutory scheme that Parliament has
gone to all that trouble to set up with
all the demerits of that process or that
jumping of the process entails how do
you get to the section 33 stage if you
cannot genuinely make a section 31
statement well my answer to that and I'm
going to come back to it in more detail
tomorrow as the next topic when I
consider how section 31 fits into this
scheme My ultimate answer to that
question given the time is so be it
Parliament Parliament has set up a
jurisdictional precondition to the
introduction of a bill into the Scottish
Parliament which is that you need to be
able to persuade
I would I was about to say even but that
would be disrespectful even your own law
officer you can't even persuade your own
law officer that you are with
incompetence
the shutters come down under the scheme
of this legislation
it'll return if I may in little more
detail to section 31 tomorrow
in that day and resume a tough ass hands
moment